[Music]
so in the interest of time let's go
ahead and get started it is my privilege
today to introduce to you dr. Eric guy
so who is the CMIO
at ocean and as you guys know ocean is
one of our valued partners for the
clinical informatics fellowship program
and also the experience I think that
consistently has got the best reviews
responses from fellows who have
participated in it Eric is an internal
medicine physician he did his medical
school from Tufts and then his residency
in internal medicine from Providence
Portland so he is a native Portlander
almost and then he comes to ocean via
Kaiser Wow so he's bringing a lot of
really interesting experiences of East
Coast medicine West Coast medicine
community health centers integrated
delivery systems and now trying to to
deliver health care to a population of
clinicians who most desperately needs
the pooled resources to provide them
with the leverage to practice medicine
in a way that many of us in academic
medical center and large community
healthcare systems have taken for
granted so I think the the mission of
ocean is a particularly interesting and
a particularly noble one for azan from
an informatics perspective and the fact
that they have you know participated so
closely in the clinical informatics
fellowship program is to is to our
benefit and although there has been a
rich tradition of ocean and which is you
collaborating on projects together I
think this is the jewel in the crown for
both institutions for collaboration and
with that I'll hand it over there thank
you Vishnu really appreciate that
I think that's the nicest introduction
if ever received that was great I wish I
would have recorded you can you hear me
okay
on the phone okay so I want to thank
everybody for being here in person and
on the phone it really is an honor to be
here Vishnu
me to do grant rounds maybe six months
or so ago and you know as with everybody
else public speaking is probably not
everyone's favorite thing it's not my
favorite thing so to say I was looking
forward to it might be a little bit
strong but I was strongly anticipating
this moment and putting these slides
together has actually been kind of fun
so I'm actually looking forward to
telling all of you guys about ochin
teaching you about ochen and sharing
with you what we've been doing with the
informatics fellowship program at OHSU
as vishnu said i'm CMIO at ocean i've
been there for a little over a year and
I currently practice medicine on Fridays
at Clackamas County Health Department
who is an ocean customer so I use the
EHR that we that we serve and I also
have this lovely adjunct position here
at OHSU I certainly don't want to turn
down the heavily subsidized trimet
sticker or the process badge that lets
me into the office so they can go to
Monica's candy jar always very
appreciated one of these days I'm hoping
that this disclaimer slide
well actually like you know I have to
make it because I have so many
investments that I have to somehow worry
about it but I don't need to worry about
it right now
so this fellowship and oceans
collaboration was really meant to be
back in 2016 only a year ago I got an
email from this guy in am Bishnu
and it started out something like this
hi Eric can we send you a fellow and I
said sure I just started who are you
and he said I'm the fellowship program
director at OHSU you may have heard of
me I'm kind of a big deal I said oh ho
fish news right who is this guy
well we're sending you an interventional
radiologist first he's really drunk the
fire kool-aid
I said oh fire fire fire kool-aid he
said you know fire fire
are you really an informatics Asst and
you know as it turns out those vishen
and I started talking we realized we
actually share a common past so some of
you may know I grew up I spent
my childhood in India and Vishnu and I
actually grew up in the same part of
India during one of his travels around
and as we were chatting I was thinking
you know it's funny we grew up in the
same part and yet we didn't really know
each other I mean I know he looks a lot
older than me but I think we're about
the same age and and so I went looking
in my photo library you know try to find
a picture of the two of us and actually
Vishnu this is my first time telling you
we actually didn't know each other in
high school and I found photographic
proof there's the two of us right there
hanging out okay enough about that so
let's talk about we're gonna talk about
today so the first thing I want to
mention is what is ochen okay a lot of
people don't know what Ocean is they see
it around they kind of see the building
on Nadeau Parkway but they don't really
know what we do then we're going to talk
about informatics at ochen which is
actually undergoing I would say a
Renaissance but that might be a little
bit optimistic I would say it is going
through a rebirth okay so this is
actually a crucial time at ocean for
informatics we'll talk about this really
productive wonderful relationship that
OHSU de maiz ocean are having together
and then we'll end with questions okay
pretty simple outline what is ocean I
get this all the time Oh Jean I see it
on care everywhere oh is that the health
information exchange that must be it
right what does it stand for
okay so today this is how I you know we
often see it right and care everywhere
this is what I saw when I was at Kaiser
was I was looking care of a when I would
see ocean I have no idea what it was I
would click on it there was some
clinical notes you know but I didn't
know what it was okay we're gonna start
with a quiz and you notice vision what's
this
yeah yeah yeah so in a nod to my brother
from another mother for his World of
Warcraft addiction every time you see
this symbol on this presentation it is
going to be indicating that this is the
answer to one of the five CM e questions
is going to be on the slide okay so this
is I'm giving you the biggest heads up
ever that if you want to get your CM e
you need to know the answer to these
questions okay
so what is Ocean stand for who thinks it
stands for Oregon Community Health
Information Network hands please okay we
got two in the room all right
Orange County healthiness Network
probably not huh outside communities
humanism in nature
no no takers okay Oh H's use community
health independent naturopaths nobody
here it doesn't stand for anything okay
the eyes have it all right so ocean used
to stand for number one Oregon Community
Health Information Network once we
expanded outside a vote Oregon it didn't
really make any sense anymore okay so
we're kind of like IBM it used to be
international business Business Machines
now is just IBM now we're just ocean
okay I've seen it actually spelt like
this before which actually kind of
prefer to this all-caps thing but you
know this is a stock slide you'll notice
the hideous background and the sort of
by the way these slides were not clear
but with my marketing department so if
you know anybody Houghton please don't
share them with these with them okay
because and by the way these didn't go
through recipient QA either so you have
no idea what you're getting but you
notice this is sort of a generic it's a
non-profit health care Innovation Center
what does that actually mean designed to
provide knowledge solutions yada yada
alright this is what I tell people
because it firms it up in their brain
especially clinicians okay we are a
nonprofit healthcare IT company say with
me we're a nonprofit healthcare IT
company okay focus on the nationwide
safety net based in Portland okay we
have a building it's actually a physical
space on Nadeau Parkway okay it's a nice
building you guys if you want to visit
by the way just get in touch with me
I'll give you a tour what we do is a
number of things okay this is
just a sample but it's a it's a core of
our business we host two different EHRs
there's a CME question on that but
there's an answer on the future slide we
run a nationwide medical grade network
so actual fiber cables to our member
sites where we host the money in hrs we
provide data aggregation we do reporting
we do visualization with that data we do
coding and billing services one thing
we'll get into is that our main
customers or FQHCs federal federally
qualified health centers the coding and
billing especially is a little bit
different for them and sometimes these
FQHCs don't have the funds to create
their own specialized coding and billing
staff so we do it for them we offer
training we do workflow engineering we
do quality improvement coaching for
clinics that are looking to transform
their business but don't really know
where to start okay
and we do a lot of research so we do
research specifically on the safety net
we'll get into that a little bit more
what don't we do Oh CME question right
got this symbol okay we don't own or
operate any of our own clinics or
healthcare organizations we are not a
deliverer of care this might change one
day we might decide that actually we
need to put some skin in the game learn
some on-the-ground skills instead of
telling people how to do things but it's
not something that's currently in our
wheelhouse okay so people say oh oh in
clinics there's no such thing as an
ocean clinic there are clinics supported
by ocean there are open customers but we
don't own any clinics ourselves
sometimes it makes it a little bit more
real for those of us in Oregon to know
who are our local customers so you know
who's on ocean there's a lot more than
this in Oregon and in Washington but
these are some of the big ones so
Clackamas County where I work Multnomah
County OHSU your Richmond escape whose
clinics don't use OHS use epic they use
oceans epic okay outside in Pacific
University Virginia Garcia and then of
course wallace medical concern when I
was in residency I volunteered at
Wallace medical concern it was all paper
charts it was great you just scribble
something and you're done and you know
now they're they they drop that kool-aid
okay I'm gonna go through this real
quick because there's a lot of stuff all
right
so where'd it a chance start mm it was
founded and initially what happened was
there were some clinics that got
together and said you know we really
want to get a robust EHR epic said yeah
you're really two small clinics all
banded together and said okay how about
now we were bigger together and that big
said okay and that was essentially the
start in a nutshell
okay and it developed as after that so
the practice-based research network was
created about seven years after creation
of ocean we became Oregon's Meaningful
Use Regional Extension Center we
integrated with a social security
administration we deployed this is
actually I want to get back to this a
little bit later we deployed two
corrections behavioral health and
naturopathic institutions that last I'm
very interested in in particular and
let's see you can see basically there's
a lot of sort of you know milestones of
how we went through and became the
company that we did this one in 2015 we
introduced a cure which is a data
aggregation engine visualization portal
for clinics that are looking to take
their medical data and report for
Meaningful Use purposes or just for
quality improvement purposes where they
can see trends they can drill down to
the actual provider drill down to the
actual patient full pH I and you only
see your own data you can't see anybody
else's data and then we started
acquiring a couple of companies most
recently in the past year so that at the
end here you know we've been hosting
epic for a decade and a half we acquired
two companies that hosts next-gen ok
this is this is a cmeek question right
here which tool EHRs do we host epic in
next-gen ok and the reason we did that
was to diversify our holdings in the EHR
market we didn't want to be entirely
epoch dependent and next-gen is the most
popular FQHC EHR it's inexpensive it
runs lightly it works pretty well we
wanted to get into that market
so we acquired a company based in
Washington State that hosted five
practices we still host them we also
acquired a next-gen
bunny that actually builds the templates
if you know next-gen you know what I
mean when I say templates for Planned
Parenthood clinics in a variety of
states so we have that expertise now as
well which has actually been great
because we can reach out to Planned
Parenthood Federation of America and ask
them questions directly that we never
had a conduit to ask them before around
women's health around reproductive
health which has been actually a really
great boon and then finally we want to
get more into the telehealth space and
so we acquired California telehealth
network that has a lot of
california-based customers they are a
telehealth Resource Center they have a
lot of internal knowledge we wanted to
tap into that
so we purchased them so now we have an
office in Seattle for the the next-gen
clients and we have an office in
California in Sacramento in order to
host the telehealth that we do and then
we're hoping to take that telehealth
knowledge and expand a nationwide here
where our customers are now I mentioned
a curate which is our data aggregation
engine you notice this is 126
organizations that's more customers than
we have on EHR that's because we don't
just have accurate customers who we host
on EHR anybody who wants data
aggregation of visualization and
reporting can come to us we don't have
to be hosting them we just need to send
up the set up the interfaces so we get
their data we do billing obviously as I
mentioned we do broadband connections so
about three-quarters of our hosted
customers are on our broadband network
and that's outside of the internet
there's always a minimum speed so they
always have a fast connection we host
106 organizations across about 18 states
on epic we host excuse me this is a
little misleading
we host five organizations on next-gen
the other 30 are those Planned
Parenthood clinics that I mentioned
where we maintain their templates but we
don't actually host them out of our
servers we do a lot of research as I
mentioned we're organ medicaid's
Meaningful Use technical assistance
programs so if an organization in Oregon
says we want to meet meaningful use
requirements and we're mostly Medicaid
they can come to us for advice and we
can help them coordinate their work
and then of course the California
telehealth Network the Haiti
organizations in California you can see
that there are states that we don't
cover this map is also a little bit
misleading in that if you look at
patient volume it's almost entirely
concentrated on the west coast and in
the Boston area we cover these
territories but the volume of patients
is more concentrated on the west coast
where we started and in the Boston area
this slide is specifically about oceans
epic business you can see in terms of
patient visits we've been growing like
hotcakes Obamacare has been good to us
okay because more people get coverage
you can pay for your health care now and
we charge on a either more patients you
see the more we get paid if you can see
more patients we're gonna benefit as
well so the more people get coverage the
better we do right it makes sense this
five times own thing can be annoying
sometimes because keep in mind we have a
single epic instance one so we don't
have a different instance of different
areas we share this entire instance
across five time zones and across the 18
states and so it can make it difficult
when there is a regulatory program that
has different criteria in different
states right there's this tool called
craft I'm an internist I don't really
know much about it all I know is that
different states require to be done in
different ages Massachusetts is 26
Oregon is 18 Indiana is 21
we want to find one tool that works
across the board building that can be
problematic but we get around it we fix
it this is another cmeek question which
population do we serve okay
the safety net okay so this is mostly
government insurance or uninsured or
underinsured these are the people that
we try to serve you can see mostly it's
female a lot of chronic conditions you
could this is probably the most
illustrative graph I think 24 percent
uninsured 40 percent Medicaid and nine
percent Medicare only a small smidgen on
private insurance
I show this slide I was actually
thinking about taking this out I mean we
do a lot of hie
care everywhere patient records I wish I
had sort of a benchmark to show you to
compare but because we are a large
organization spread out across a lot of
different clinics there's gonna be a lot
of hie I left it in just because we're
proud of it
you know for there's one thing we do
really well it's technology and hie in
particular our CTO is on the board of
the sequoia project so he's had a large
hand in directing the progress of care
quality and so this is something that is
most definitely a strengths and
interfaces are also a strength for us
keep in mind that we need to interface
with the labs that our partners all work
with so if a clinic has three different
labs that they use they use quests they
use lab core they use some private
company we need to somehow create an
interface with them it comes into our
mirth interface engine and we need to
maintain every single one of those
interfaces because each one of those
discrete lab codes then drive the
reporting on which the clinics depend
for their financial health right so this
is a really important piece of what we
do so since our customers are all spread
out so do our employees have to be most
of us are in Oregon but certainly not
all we're spread across really all the
time zones except for Alaska and Hawaii
obviously we don't have any clinics in
Hawaii I think that's an oversight we
should probably do that so I can do site
visits you can see that our our most of
our employees really are in the
technical category we are growing our
professional services I'm actually not
sure why this is showing up this way
looked fine on my computer but apologies
for that one thing I think is really
cool is that 64% of our staff are female
which I think for a tech company is
probably unusual I haven't actually done
any comparisons so I don't truly know
that but I believe that's true our CEO
is a woman I see oh oh is a woman
our cxo chief experience officer is a
woman we've got a lot of leaders at the
executive level and a middle management
level who are female and I think that's
actually fantastic
we divide up our remote employees into
so-called member care teams who are
responsible for region there are five
individuals on a single member kit
member care team there's the reporting
person so anybody who knows about
meaningful use reporting etc needs to be
on that team the billing service is so H
and billing services OBS an account
executive who's really the umbrella
person responsible for the entire
contract obviously if it's an epic
customer and Epicure analyst and then a
resolute analyst and they work and live
in the different states that you see
here this is our projection for the next
few years we're going to keep on growing
now I'm not a strategist I'm not on the
team that decides where we're gonna go
as a company this is a another stock
slide but it shows that our plan is to
keep on growing we're around here right
now in the 400 area and you can see that
the ratio of professional services to
technical is intended to grow as well
and this is in no small part due to our
desire to really become a center of
thought around how to take care of
underprivileged populations
right now we're providing a lot of
really good technical services and we're
providing some really good support
services professional support services
but it's an area in which we can get
better and hence my earlier reference to
we don't run any clinics we don't run
any healthcare organizations but maybe
if we're going to get into the space we
kind of need to so we know what it's
like to actually walk the walk I'll jump
over to research now we do a lot of
research on the safety net our say our
our data set on the underserved
I keep hearing one of the largest or is
the largest in the country I don't
really know what it is it's big and I'll
show you a slide that shows you the
number of patient lives that are in that
database
but since creating the research program
and many of you probably know Jen DeVoe
who's currently the chair of family
medicine here at OHSU she was our chief
research officer until about a year ago
and so she's headlined a lot of this
work
and in 2017 you can see the sort of
numbers that were really proud of in
terms of the balling of research that we
do now there's a really good reason for
that
right if you do a lot of really good
research you're more likely to get
grants
I'm completely my salary's complete
completely paid for by grants which
means I'm on like seven research
projects which has been really
interesting for me and also helps with
with paying the bills obviously these
are our research priorities chronic pain
opioids we'll talk a little bit more
about that in a second
disease is affecting the safety net
primarily chronic conditions health
equity health policy informatics and
research data warehouse practice
transformation reproductive and Family
Health especially with our relationship
with Planned Parenthood now that's been
an important addition and then social
determinants of health which everybody
is talking about these days we are
engaged with epic on an almost weekly
basis in helping them design their
social terms of health tools which are
going to be receiving a the primarily
big rollout with a 2018 version which i
believe is going to be released in March
or April so I was mentioning this slide
would come up this talks about our the
size of our data set so an epoch alone
we have two million unique patients in
our research database we have three and
a half our curate data aggregation so
again this is our aggregation engine
right has a lot of patients as well with
the next-gen data 1.8 million and then
together all together about 10 million
there's a little bit of overlap but not
if not a huge amount you'll notice if
you're looking at the columns that let's
see where was it here we go so with our
epic and research and accurate data
aggregation about half of the patients
that we have are at or below 100% of the
federal poverty line and you see that
decreases with next-gen and that's the
the Planned Parenthood Edition because
the five practices that we host are all
FQHC so they actually have the same
demographics as these other groups case
you're looking for discrepancies in
these columns
and we also offer a variety of other
things so I mentioned the professional
services so we provide quality
improvement process improvement
consulting revenue cycle management
network design technical services
management services if an FQHC says we
need help with something we probably
have a service for you and finally in
terms of what we offer
we provide a training institute and this
is not just for our customers it's
actually for our own staff as well so
when I first joined Ocean
I had never bothered learning reporting
workbench and one of the first oli
courses that was provided was how to use
reporting workbench so I took it it was
very helpful I took a quiz and I learned
so this is something that's free to
ocean staff there is a price a cost for
any members that we have that want to
take an oli course but we we provide
this and actually I'll talk about dr.
Chynn sale of honey in a second who
actually became a nolle presenter twice
while he was doing his rotation and
taught our members the basics and
advanced skills of coding and
documentation okay so that's about ocean
so let me stop there for a second and
see if there any questions if there any
conceptual queries you have about you
know what is OSHA and what do we do etc
please
I've got a mic coming up behind you
could you talk a little bit more about
the kinds of research that you're doing
so I I saw all the different areas that
you're doing research in but like what
kind of study designs and approaches
you're using the ap2 so I will so first
of all not a researcher so when it gets
to design I start feeling a little bit
uncomfortable I'll tell you what I'm
involved in directly I'll give you two
or three examples so there is a group in
Minnesota called Health Partners
Institute or HPI they have created a
clinical decision support tool around
cardiovascular health which is a
fantastic tool that takes in a patient's
data crunches it through their
proprietary algorithm which is created
by a combination of various
evidence-based guidelines but they put
it all together
and based on those inputs they then give
you a set of recommendations to the
provider but also to the patient saying
these are all things that are important
but your priority number one today is
this
so obviously the person is a smoker
that's always priority number one take
that aside how do you know whether it's
more important meaning what reduces
their risk the most if they lower their
blood pressure or take a statin for
their cholesterol right this algorithm
tells me that and so it presents it in
front of the patient first while the
patient's waiting for the provider which
is a great use of that time right
because they're always waiting and says
these are the things your doctors can
talk to you about today this is priority
number one this is priority number two
this is prior to number three so by its
how the doctor comes in and he or she
has their own sheet that says pretty
much the same thing but in more doctor
language it says these are the things
you should talk to your patient about so
they sit down and they've already both
had internal monologues about the same
data and the same recommendations and so
we're engaged in working with HPI to
make this tool a reality within our epic
for some 30 clinics I think there's 30
in the control group and there's third
in the intervention group or at 60 and
60 I can't remember
and the idea is in the FQHC population
does this kind of tool lead to really
good surrogate outcomes that would make
us want to expand it across the entire
collaborative so that's one example
another example that I'm working on is
we're working with a researcher at
Virginia Commonwealth University and
Alex Crist Alex is on the USPSTF so he
obviously comes with you know excellent
background in terms of what he's trying
to do what he's trying to do is create
an interactive personal patient portal
experience around preventive care and
what you do is as a patient as you log
into epics portal which of course is my
chart and you go to the my preventive
care module and my preventive care has
already downloaded your information from
your chart about what vaccinations
you've had what screenings you've had or
what you haven't and it educates the
patient and friendly patient friendly
language about why it's important to do
these things that you haven't already
done and then the next time you go see
your doctor maybe you should talk to
them about this right the preliminary
data is just preliminary shows a
doubling in the recommended screening
and vaccination rates in the FQHC
population something is that has not
been shown with this technology before
to my knowledge and that was presented
Knapp Craig a couple weeks ago so those
are two examples I'm trying to think
about I worry that I'm not going to give
you a representative sample because I'm
obviously involved specifically based on
my skill set I'd like to if you're if
you're interested I'd like to put you in
touch with the actual researchers at OGN
so you can get a better answer okay
you're welcome
basically it's health IT tech not let me
tell technology essentially research
those two those two projects certainly
do I don't want to make a generalized
statement just yet yeah of course thank
you other questions miss oh and I should
have mentioned if you need see Emmy for
this course contact Lynne and she will
hook you up with CME I should have said
that at the beginning every can you go
back one slide for just one more one
more
there you go so this to me was really
exciting when I saw it because to me you
know trying to mine the EHR data is the
obvious thing to do with the EHR now in
2017 but if we fundamentally believe
that that the purpose of delivery of
healthcare and the use of technology
like the EHR in healthcare is to improve
the health of populations then the gold
standard that we should be held
responsible to is how do we manage to
improve the healthcare of the lower
strata of our society the vulnerable the
disenfranchised folks the people who are
traditionally you know utilizing the
safety net and so it really to me this
this grass suggests an extraordinary
opportunity to bring up the level of the
healthcare of the nation from the bottom
up as opposed to how we traditionally do
it which is the top down and so my
question to you is that I know you guys
are doing stuff with this data and I'm
sure that you will disseminate your
findings but the kind of tools and
techniques that you use to mind these
this data do you have some kind of a
strategy at auction or a long-term
vision of how you're going to allow
other organizations to do the same kind
of innovative things with the data for
safety net populations as you're doing
in Ocean yeah thank you Vishnu so we
partner with other CDR ends around the
country and they have access you know
through data use agreements we have
access to their data they have access to
our data we're always open to doing
those kinds of partnerships so that
there's a mutual you know give-and-take
to that the other intriguing possibility
is something that
actually Jim Morrison came up with which
was when he was scoping out whether or
not a cure A's
hl7 connections could all be upgraded to
fire connections so that we could create
a fire API and others could query those
same data but that's not something
that's built out just yet to answer your
question though the partnerships that we
do are something we want to continue so
that data set is always available to
others I move on to our informatics team
so late 2016 when I joined this was the
informatics team now keep in mind this
is an organization that has serviced
about 5000 providers 4,500 5,000
providers hundred plus organizations
complicated build that has to be spread
out across those 18 states that's a lot
of work for this team to do solely and
the strain was starting to show part of
the reason that I was hired last year
was because they were looking to really
grow their informatics team to try to
make it so that you didn't have
individuos occasional individuals making
really really important decisions
without discussing unmess and so scott
fields who some of you may know has been
a long-time member of the family
medicine department here at OHSU and
he's also our CMO currently Karen Parr
who is a practicing nurse practitioner
at OHSU Richmond so using oceans epic
was full-time primary care clinical for
Madison as well and does she's actually
was an analyst by training before she
became an informatics so she was a nurse
practitioner got her analyst
certification and was working in the
analyst space and then moved back into
the clinical informatics roll and then
Shana Zagar who is a or was a practicing
social worker decided to become trained
as an analyst and then then joined ochen
and has served in the capacity for
behavioral health mental health
addiction medicine and both have done
terrific job but they both also only
have 24 hours in a day work five days a
week actually both of them probably work
seven days a week and there needed to be
more pass
so we grew the team so this was a year
later the team has really expanded you
can see Shawn is still there and where's
Karen Karen's still there and then
Scott's still there but we add all these
other people and these are their
credentials and roles so I'll just very
quickly go through them
Anisha comes from 11 years of
Informatics experience in Atlanta where
she did mostly inpatient and pharmacy
but rose very quickly to become an
operational manager and does that
exceedingly well so she and I are
partners we basically have a dotted line
in the hierarchy at ochen where she
essentially manages operations pushes
things through makes things happen and
everybody reports to her instead of to
me which I'm very happy about um
Julianne has ten years of OB experience
at Multnomah County Oh Oh
interesting people on the phone we had a
technical glitch
I lied you were here turning the
projector on right now
projectors coming on thank you for
helping to figure it out well I'll take
questions right now while we're waiting
please yeah we cover less than 10% of
the FQHC market in the country I think I
heard last year was like 5%
I haven't verified those numbers but we
have a tiny section of what's available
the FQHCs eventually find a way they
have to and and they hear from us here
about us from mostly word-of-mouth where
they say oh you know I we thought we
were too small to get epic so we want
epic end this is the way to get it right
we also get referrals actually from epic
directly so epic says hey we got this
customer or this wannabe customer but
they're too small or whatever do you
want to reach out to them and then most
recently we've actually had some large
healthcare systems say you know we could
extend our instance out to them but it's
not business savvy for us to do so
but we want them on Epic so we can do
better more discreet hie would you be
willing to work with them so that we can
communicate through care everywhere with
them but we don't actually want to host
them ourselves
so it just kind of depends on what
they're in the market for I won't lie
our services are not cheap right so it
may be that the price tag is actually
still too high for them that they still
want to go and get their own next-gen
instance or something that's a little
bit less expensive but I'm not really
sure where the price cut off is because
we have clinics where there's one
provider and we have clinics that have
thousands of providers you know so maybe
that's exaggerating maybe hundreds
Molina Healthcare is our largest
customer I don't know how many providers
they have but they have the most out of
all of our customers so the this the
range in size this really spans the
gamut we do notice that the
organizations that have that are
smaller tend to engage with us less so
we have a number of workgroups another
of number of them committees that we
asked our members to come and join us
and have conversations with us the large
and medium-sized ones always show up a
table the small ones don't and that's
probably because they just don't have
the staff to spare even got one provider
and they're always seeing patients
they're never going to come to a
committee meeting right so I not being
involved in the business space I'm not
sure what the denominator is of people
who could be our customers and how we
increase the numerator of those but yeah
I mean it's feels to me like we're
providing a good service that as your
question okay oh we're back awesome
thank you thank you okay so I'll keep
going so Julianne has about ten years of
OB experience at Multnomah County she
joined us as a trainer and she joins us
on our calls to help make determinations
on OB questions that oh please
one of your grits Oh graduates oh okay I
don't think I knew that
actually she's yep yep yeah I knew about
Brian and Tom but I did not know about
Julie so I have to I have to go bug her
she's very humble and the Stacey Carney
is a practicing internist who also uses
oceans epic at neighborhood health
center and is now our lead for clinical
decision support as of actually this
week which I'm exceedingly excited about
we'll talk a little bit more about that
Cherie done handles our health
maintenance she's a nurse and a senior
analyst Scott have already talked about
Clairefontaine as a workflow consultant
spent many years as a nurse practitioner
especially an STD clinic so brings a lot
of that experience with her christy gray
is a practice coach she's an
occupational therapist we don't get a
lot of questions about OT but we do we
know who to go to
Marshall Hammond is a senior application
analyst also a nurse practitioner
doesn't currently practice anymore but
has that clinical knowledge obviously an
experienced Joe Nelson is fantastic
person trained as a PA really good at
what she does in quality
and is the kind of person who isn't
gonna say something to make you feel
good she's going to tell you the truth
and it's always helpful to have somebody
around I mentioned Karen already Jeff
Richter is one of our most important
people he is apt by training but has a
wealth of experience in the software
industry actually in a product
development and serves as basically the
manager of all things on our team and
then I mentioned Shana as already as
well there are non clinicians working in
the informatics space who nevertheless
have a lot of really helpful experience
for us we may be talked about Tom Durkin
Maureen comes with the next-gen package
when we when we purchased the company
that hosts Maureen came with our
certifications see all the initials
after her name indicating all her
knowledge and then Pam who used to work
in the dental industry is now
responsible for dental projects for epic
wisdom for example or for identic
dendrix installations and then Lily Tran
who basically coordinates a lot of our
activities so the whole purpose of the
previous two slides is to show you that
informatics at Ocean is really changing
and growing almost by the month and this
this slide is going to get bigger
there's going to be more people we're
going to add and we actually have a job
opening that we just posted yesterday
actually that will increase our next-gen
capability from the clinical standpoint
I've had to learn next-gen and actually
went up to practice in Seattle for three
or four months just like one and a half
days two days a month just so I could
learn it from the user perspective
because we didn't have the clinical
knowledge of next-gen or as a user at
ochen when we acquire the company and we
felt that that was important so
thankfully one of the clinics that we
host was willing to let me go up and see
patients and my washing license actually
became useful alright so what do we do
so we provide clinical input and
informatics input on anything and
everything and the volume of email that
I was receiving was astronomical when
our team was smaller and we didn't have
defined rules that's gotten a lot better
the pinging has reduced and that's
because we're creating more of a
structure around how we do business and
I think that's an important point to
mention that in this very operational
job we've really had to try to be kinder
to ourselves in how we help out the rest
of the company we are responsible for
having the clinical conversations with
our customers remember our customers our
healthcare organizations something we
don't do right and they are physicians
their medical directors there are also
operational leaders and executive
leaders and those leaders can talk to my
CEO and co but the medical customers the
MDS the do is the NP is the PAS the
nurses who have clinical questions
that's my job that's my team's job to
try to answer their questions and come
to resolution on any issues that they
bring up we realized early on that we
don't provide optimization training to
clinics that don't have any other way of
getting it so they get an epic
installation they do they see patients
but nobody's telling them how to do it
better
nobody's telling them how to be more
efficient right and epic does have some
resources available on their user web
that pops up that says you know you
could do this you could do that but
there's no systematic way of pushing
content to our customers how are we
doing good on time 15 minutes until the
end or 15 minutes until quit okay so
I've got five minutes till Q&A right
okay thank you and so we've really been
working on that obviously our favorite
thing is to sponsor the OHSU informatics
experience which we'll talk about a
little bit more and then we sponsor the
physician builder program that's out of
epic I'm going to start speeding through
a little bit just to give enough time so
when inputs come in product enhancement
from our from our IT team research
questions member tickets on complaints
or recommendations for improvements
regulatory requirements again state
specific regulatory requirements and
federal regulatory requirements any
changes from epic themselves any
requests from ocean leadership any
requests that our own team dreams up
funnels through to this group called the
change advisory board on which we do
have a seat and typically this is a
technical can we and should we from
from a design perspective if that passes
that it comes to our team for clinical
vetting we then run it by the clinical
analyst to make sure that it's buildable
we take it to our clinical operations
review community committee which means
twice a month this is where our members
our clinical members sit down with us
and discuss what we proposed to them
remember their inputs are to go through
here so this is kind of a one-way
conversation we tell them what we
recommend and then they return survey
data to us indicating whether or not
they agree or disagree then it comes
back to us
we've massaged a little bit more than we
send it to the analysts to build in a
nutshell this is our process we have an
opportunity with our larger team to
build product ownership into our teams
so that Eric is not responsible for all
of it and Karen's also not responsible
for all of it and Shawn is also not
responsible for all of it
we each have our niche and this is new
for us and this is why you've got all
these question marks we're still working
on this to determine what's the best use
of our time from a personnel standpoint
as you can imagine there's a lot of
disagreement right some people really
want to hang on to this and another
person also once I hang on to the same
thing how do we divvy it up in a way
that feels fair a few areas I really
wish had more time to go through this
but clinical decision support is my
number one priority at ochen it is not
something we focused on in the past few
years now that we have a clinical team
that can do it now that we have a
physician lead for clinical decision
support this is going to become our
number one priority from the clinical
informatics perspective provider
efficiency is something that it kills me
when someone does something
inefficiently when they're seeing
patients because they could use all that
time seeing the patient and not clicking
away so something we've actually
invested a lot of resources into we're
providing these resources for free to
our members in order to make them better
I probably don't need to say too much
about this everybody knows that this is
a crisis this is something that we're
working actually directly with epic I'm
trying to make better within our system
patient portals is a actually a big
priority of epics they would like more
patients to use patient portals and
they're coming to us and saying what can
you do
to drive patient portal adoption in the
safety net population and you'll notice
our adoption rates only 18% the national
average is actually only 25% which
surprised me but the large behemoths
that really know what they're doing 70
80 % now we have a range between zero
and 85% we have a clinic that's in San
Francisco that has just made it their
way of communicating and so it's an
opt-out procedure we're trying to drive
more of our customers to that there's a
variety of issues that come about with
FQHC markets in that patient portal
usage may not actually make sense for a
lot of patients take Multnomah County
for example their Mid County clinic half
their patients speak English or Spanish
the other half speak one of seventy
other languages but not English or
Spanish how do you drive patient portal
adoption with that population right one
in two patients isn't going to really
use it for communication and we're
really pushing the epic physician
builder program there's some research
from class showing that organizations
that have physician builders have
happier physicians okay that's
correlational data there's lots of
confounders I get it
but we're trying to make our
organizations have more skin in the game
do some of the build themselves and
we've developed guardrails so that the
physicians who we don't own who we don't
employ are building in our dev
environment so that they can make things
that their organization benefit from and
even better maybe that the collaborative
benefits from okay so Jim who you all
probably know and love came and wrote an
exceedingly good white paper on how to
change our hl7 connections for a data
aggregation engine all over the fire he
presented to our executive leadership
team it was the only time I've seen Jim
nervous he doesn't usually get nervous
and there he is in front of our CEO
who's always got you know that look and
and he did a terrific job and I actually
our former CIO started planning started
making strategic planning based on his
findings oh yeah CME question we started
hosting last year 2016 not 1995 okay
okay so in-ho went and did something
that nobody else could do at Ocean which
was he started investigating really down
to the menu detail of direct addresses
why some transitions of care
were failing forth some of the practices
that really needed the money from
meaningful use and he actually he wrote
this this report showing how to avoid
the problem of the future because there
was a combination of bad documentation
bad training bad maintenance of direct
addresses he figured it all out
really amazing service Ben's been to
ochen twice the first time he took the
BlueCross BlueShield health index and
basically said let's try the same with
OSHA and data and found some and had
some really interesting findings which
he then made into a poster which some of
you may have seen I'm going really fast
I realized this but that's because I
know we're running out of time most
recently and I don't want to steal his
thunder so I'm not going to give you all
his his results because he hasn't
published yet but basically he looked at
epics provider efficiency profile which
of these gigantic forty megabyte Excel
spreadsheets that show every click
providers have done in the organization
and try to correlate up clinical quality
metric outcomes which actually have been
very interesting preliminary data and
the famous doctor chisel body built an
opioid smart set which is actually
forming the basis of our larger opioid
billed at OSHA and we actually have a
number of organizations that have gotten
the Ames grant funding that they are now
using to help fund the build and I niece
started it also he did some research on
the rules around clinical documentation
and code in the outpatient space and the
presented two webinars along with myself
and Karen Parr one of our informatics
ists to the membership so that the
doctors can figure out what do they
actually have document what can they
remove from their loaded notes and then
I love this picture I took this
yesterday he's so relaxed so Brady
created a code mapping tool named
Cardinal which are a cure a leadership
has actually prioritized as a top
priority for a development because it
makes code mapping easy for data
validation and currently he's working on
also a grant supported novel
customizable c.d.s tool
did I mention CVS is one of my top
priority that consolidates all point of
care information and makes it an HR
agnostic set of recommendations that we
could potentially show to epoch
customers and next-gen
and any other customers who might want
to do that in the future he's creating a
prototype obviously not building the
whole thing ocean really loves the
fellowship program and what all I do is
I basically just say all right here's
dr. so-and-so let's open some doors
let's see what he or she can do and the
rest sort of takes care of itself really
in the last couple months I've been
extraordinarily busy and poor Ani has
had to suffer my absence at hojin as I'm
travelling here and there so I've
started building my team around the
program so that they can be supportive
of the fellows when I'm not available to
be there now fellows are adult learners
so they don't usually need much you know
they as long as you open the doors for
them give them a way to contact you give
them a direction or help work with them
so they come up with their direction
they can just do their own thing and
I've been so impressed with the
intelligence that drive the
determination direction that every
fellow that's come through has shown and
I'm very excited about the program
continuing we also now have a permanent
desk for fellows something that I need
iddin benefit from I don't think when he
was there but Brady's the first one so
it is now the fellow desk which is good
well one thing that that vision and I
have talked a little bit about but we
should talk about in more details how do
we integrate the clinical experience at
our member clinics remember we don't own
them but we can certainly have
conversations with them about how do we
bring this fellow in to really see what
it's like to do informatics at the
clinic level as opposed to at the ocean
level this is my last slide and how much
time do we have for questions right now
in six minutes I apologize for bringing
too much content and taking too long to
present it but questions for me
mic people on the phone so in terms of
numbers what's the relationship of the
proportion of epic and next-gen
customers at this point in oh it's well
there's a hundred and six organizations
on Epic and five organizations on
next-gen that we host the next-gen
customers that are on Planned Parenthood
excuse me the Planned Parenthood
customers that use next-gen use an
instance that we don't that we don't
host while we support their templates so
it's mostly epic in fact if you come and
you know see our work groups etc they're
almost always a little too epic centric
considering we're also a next-gen shop
now and we're trying to be cognizant of
that and trying to be conscious of that
especially when we talk to the customers
right because we're talking to them
we're starting to use epic terms they're
not going to understand it it's
something we keep on having to pinch
ourselves and say alright just remind
yourself you know keep it a charge not
stick the language so I dealt with this
a little bit when when I was working on
the opiate project but I was hoping you
could talk about it more with the group
of when you're spread out across the
country and we talk about
standardization versus customization how
do you make that decision or how are
those conversations had about we want to
build something and we want to roll it
out to all the providers well do we you
know how do we think about it so that
810 provider clinic in Seattle at versus
a 30 provider clinic in Virginia how do
we make sure that our build is going to
be successful regardless of where you
know it's being implemented how do you
decide how much we standardize and how
much we customize yeah great a lot of
emotional conversations frankly so we
start out with the idea that if there's
something that's regulatory then we have
to do it and you know whether that's
federal or state that is sort of our
bottom line right there's no choice
really
if it's something like health
maintenance where we're doing
vaccinations or preventive screenings
we've settled on USPSTF as being sort of
our guiding principle now anything
outside of that or somebody says yep but
for our bait
population we really need to do this you
know for example if you've got a mostly
homeless population because you are
Boston Central for the homeless then
you're probably going to TV screen
everybody right but we don't have a
health maintenance topic that says TB
screening for everybody so for those
customers who are outside of the norm we
build them custom build where it's
possible
so our usual go-to is actually best
practice advisories because those have
the most malleability when it comes to
organization of specific needs because
other organizations won't see those but
every organization will see health
maintence so it depends on the tool if
there's a tool that we can use to
customize we'll do it if we can't we
need to decide by consensus not
unanimity so we take it to that court
meeting the clinical operations review
committee and we say here's what this
organization is suggesting we think it's
a good idea bad idea what do you think
and typically it's majority rules
if somebody's operational workflows are
severely impact by a decision that's
made by majority and they let us know
afterwards we just revisit it you know
if it's not regulatory we've always got
time to discuss it and we meet twice a
month and so we just keep on taking it
back
make our informatics recommendation but
ultimately the customers pay the bills
and so if there's something they want
and we don't think it's going to break
anything or we don't think it's a
terrible idea
then we'll generally do our best to
implement it so it's a lot of discussion
basically but that is one of the
Bugaboos is of this work is trying to
find good enough consensus so thank you
so much for your kind words about the
fellows of course my question is so I
actually thought of this when the lights
went out it is so you have a bunch of
customers so what special challenges do
you face during down times and how do
you kind of meet those challenges
because it's hard enough trying to deal
with it and in its institution but you
have some control over the end-user in
your case they're scattered across the
country and scattered across time zone
yeah you mean schedule down times or
unexpected down times okay yeah so our
main method of messaging is email
and what we require of our contract is
that there's always somebody the
organization paid for by the customer
called a site specialist at least one
per organization larger ones have
multiple site specialists they're our
main conduit of information if there is
a scheduled downtime we always schedule
it for a weekend remember these are all
ambulatory shops we have no hospitals
okay so there there's a very small
minority of our customers that work on
the weekends but most of them are Monday
through Friday which makes actually
scheduling down times not that hard so
we'll usually say we're gonna schedule
it for 3:00 to 5:00 a.m. on Sunday you
know the chance that somebody is working
at that hour probably pretty slim but we
communicated weeks in advance and we try
to fit it with our we have a schedule
where we say we won't do it except for
and I don't know the details it's like
third Sunday of the month if it's
scheduled it's gonna be on this time and
we might use that space or we might not
depending on what's necessary so we just
communicated really well and there's
really no choice if there's a down time
there's a down time we've got to do it
for whatever if it's unscheduled the
method of communication is still email
and urgent email to the site specialist
so the site specialists job is to
monitor that email for anything that's
coming along now if there's a downtime
they instantly know it right everything
shuts down nothing works
and the site specialist immediately goes
to their email and we also have a web
portal that shows the status of the
various technologies that we have at
ojen whether it's a cure a whether it's
epic whether it's next-gen that shows
you know if it's red line obviously it's
down and the ETA next to it as well as
the explanation and then when it gets
updated the web portal when it turns to
green it says what was the problem why
did it happen and this was the
resolution there is a downside to this
method which is that everything hinges
on the quality of the site specialist
and if they don't do a good job of
communicating with their custom with
their clinicians the clinicians might
reach out directly to us and say what
happened but they're supposed to reach
out to their site specialists say what
happened in site specialist is supposed
to be the person who communicates that
information our downtime has actually
been very low compared to the epic hours
like we get an executive dashboard
summary of our performance and compared
to the nation hour down down times
on the lower end of probability other
questions
well if you have questions later on my
email address is right there fuel foodie
and email me anytime if any of you want
a tour of ocean the physical building
I'm happy to give it anytime and I have
business cards with me if you want to
walk away with one as well so really
appreciate everybody's attention and
great questions and I hope this was
helpful thank you
[Applause]